creo que ustedes ya han escuchado la
palabra división con anterioridad cuando
alguien les pide que dividan algo ya sea
dinero entre tu hermano y tú o algo
parecido en esencia se trata de cortar o
repartir algo es dividir
divide
digamos que tengo cuatro monedas tengo
cuatro monedas iguales uno dos tres
cuatro y digamos que vemos dos personas
y quiero dividir estas monedas entre
nosotros aquí voy a dibujar me es más o
menos yo aquí de perfil con una nariz
extraña
ay dios ok bueno aquí está el cabello
aunque no lo tengo exactamente así pero
bueno ustedes se dan una idea y
aquí hay otras personas y parece que
tengo bigote pero bueno no me voy a
distraer más en el dibujo aquí hay otra
persona vamos a dibujarlo también de
perfil
y queremos dividir estas monedas entre
nosotros dos
cómo lo vamos a hacer entonces aquí
tengo cuatro monedas vamos a notarlo
tengo cuatro monedas
y los dividiremos entre dos personas
personas y hago énfasis en este 2
vamos a dividir cuatro maneras entre dos
y probablemente ustedes ya han hecho
algo por el estilo que sucede pues cada
uno de nosotros va a tener dos monedas
/ estas monedas en dos grupos que tienen
la misma cantidad
tengo dos monedas aquí hay un grupo de
monedas que le pongo grupo uno
aquí hay otro grupo de monedas
que se llaman grupo 2
y bueno el total que tenía yo eran
cuatro monedas todas estos las divide en
dos grupos que tienen la misma cantidad
de monedas cada uno cuántas monedas
tiene pues aquí hay una moneda dos
monedas y aquí hay una moneda y dos
monedas
dos grupos con dos monedas cada uno como
escribimos esto matemáticamente cuatro
monedas entre dos
y el resultado es que a cada uno le
tocan dos monedas
en este ejemplo para mostrarles que la
división es algo que ustedes ya han
usado otra cosa que vemos aquí es que
esto es lo opuesto a la multiplicación
si yo dijera que tengo dos grupos de dos
monedas y multiplicamos los dos grupos
por las dos monedas dos grupos
dos monedas que tiene cada grupo me va a
dar un total de cuatro monedas
en cierto modo ambos dicen lo mismo pero
de diferente manera vamos a hacer más
ejemplos para que esto quede claro
cuánto es 6
entre 3 vamos a dibujar 6 objetos no sé
se me ocurre en dibujar 6 limones 123
456 limones y quiero dividirlo entre 3
una forma de hacerlo es pensar que
quiero formar tres grupos iguales de
limones si tres personas van a compartir
estos limones cuántos tendrán cada uno
bueno puedo separar los hacía que hay un
grupo u otro grupo y otro tercer grupo y
así cada grupo tiene exactamente cuántos
limones pues tienen 12 1 2
12 cada grupo tiene 2 limones así que
esta división es igual a 2
resolverlo es aunque no es muy diferente
es bueno verlo de esta otra manera
también si yo quiero dividir 6 entre 3
de nuevo 6
entre 3 / 3
no sé voy a dibujar cerezas tengo 6
cerezas
1 2 3 4 5 6 cerezas y en lugar de hacer
3 grupos iguales quiero hacer grupos de
3 cerezas cuando los grupos de 3 tendré
tengo aquí un grupo de 3
otro grupo de 3
y son dos grupos así que 633 aquí
también me da que es igual a 2 pero aquí
son dos grupos con tres elementos cada
uno al pensar en estas relaciones vemos
una relación entre 6 dividido entre dos
y seis dividido entre 3 cuánto es 6
entre 2 veamos
6 entre 2 vamos a dividir 6 en dos
grupos
voy a tenernos en las mismas 6 cerezas 1
2 3 4 5 6 y ahora lo divido entre 2 aquí
dos grupos pues me quedan tres elementos
en cada uno se siente nos va a ser igual
a 3 ahora veamos lo de la otra manera 6
entre 26 entre 2
hago mis tres elementos aquí
perdón y seis elementos aquí que quiero
dividir y agrupamos en grupos de dos
elementos y ahora lo voy a agrupar de
manera diferente nada más pues para ver
qué puede ser un poco desordenado aquí
la forma del agrupamiento ok tenemos
grupos de dos elementos y son 1 2 3
grupos 6 entre 2 es igual a 3 pero no
ten algo que coincidencia que 63 es
igual a 2 y que seis entre dos es igual
a 36 entre 2 es igual a 3
en 6 entre 3 es igual a 2
esto es porque 2 por 3 6
digamos que tenemos dos grupos de tres
elementos voy a dibujarlos aquí en
desorden
y quiero hacer dos grupos de tres dos
grupos de tres
aquí están mis grupos de tres tengo dos
grupos así que dos grupos de tres son
seis dos por tres
son seis o pensando lo de la otra manera
tres grupos de dos dibujó mis elementos
1 2 3 4 5 6 y ahora voy a hacer grupos
de 2
estos dos estos dos y estos dos
tres grupos de dos también me va a dar
seis en los vídeos de multiplicación
vimos que el orden no importa pero esa
es la razón por la que el dividir seis
cosas en grupos de dos obtenemos tres o
si tenemos seis y lo dividimos en grupos
de tres nos da dos hagamos otro par de
ejemplos para comprender bien de qué
trata la división voy a hacer espacio
acá
queremos dividir 9 entre 4
9 / 4 vamos a dibujar nuestros 9
elementos 123456789
y vamos a dividirlos en grupos de cuatro
lo que aquí tengo tres agarré un
elemento por acá
y agarró estos cuatro y me queda este me
sobra un elemento a estas obras le
llamamos residuos ya que esto no lo
puedo dividir en un grupo de cuatro no
lo puedo agrupar con otros elementos más
porque no existen la respuesta aquí y
con esto tenemos un nuevo concepto 924
es igual a dos grupos
un residuo de 1 ahora quiero dividir 12
entre 4 vamos a escribirlo por acá junto
entre 4
voy a dibujar mis 12 elementos veamos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 vamos a
dividirlo entonces en grupos de cuatro
pues aquí uno dos tres cuatro
no se me ocurre también que los puede
agrupar así aquí tengo cuatro y aquí
tengo otros cuatro vaya aquí no tengo
nada que me sobre puede dividir
exactamente 12 objetos en grupos de
cuatro y nos quedaron tres grupos 2
entre 4 es igual a 3
ahora hagamos 12 entre 3 12 entre 3
hemos aprendido aquí pues podemos decir
que es igual a 4 pero vamos a probarlo
de nuevo hago mis 12 elementos
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
ahora son grupos de tres un grupo de
tres otro grupo de tres
es grupos de tres y el último grupo de 3
1 2 3 4 grupos 12 / 13 es igual a 4
vamos a hacer otro en el que quizá haya
residuo
ahora quiero dividir 14
entre 5
1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 aquí están mis 14
divide a mano en grupos de cinco
elementos 1 2 3 4 5 aquí hay un grupo
aquí abajo hay otro grupo de 5 y aquí
tengo nada más 4 no los puedo agrupar en
5 porque ya no hay más elementos así que
la respuesta es 14 entre 5 es igual a 2
un residuo de cuatro de lo que hemos
visto no siempre podremos dibujar todos
los objetos y agruparlos como lo hemos
hecho aquí hay otra forma de ver esto 14
entre 5 es lo mismo que tener 14
entre 5 aquí nos preguntamos cuántas
veces cabe el 5 en el 14
veamos 5 por 1 es igual a 5
5 por 2 igual a 10
5 x 3
igual a 15 pero 15 ya es mayor ya nos
estamos pasando entonces el que nos
sirve es el 5 por 2 que nos da 10 aquí
escribimos el 2 hacemos la
multiplicación 5 por 2 10
al 14 le restamos estos 10 y nos queda 4
es mi residuo que es el mismo residuo
que obtuvimos aquí vamos a hacer otro
problema usando esta anotación tengo 8
/ 2
a que va a ser igual esto
lo puedo escribir como aquí el 8 dentro
de la casita entre 2
hagamos la multiplicación la tabla del 2
2 por 1 2 2 por 2 aunque voy a poder
ahorrarme pasos para encontrar alguna
multiplicación un número porque x 2 es
el que más al 8 pero vamos a hacerlo
aquí paso a paso
por 30
y 2 por 48 aquí encontramos el número
exacto así que aquí ponemos 42 por 48 8
menos 80 tenemos nuestra división exacta
que esto es igual entonces a 4
ahora usamos el primer método si yo
dibujara ocho objetos en desorden
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho y tengo que hacer grupos de dos
este es un grupo otro grupo otro grupo y
otro grupo cuántos grupos tengo uno dos
tres cuatro este es el resultado de mi
división espero que hayan encontrado
esto útil y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo